well you're looking now at live pictures
of the US Capitol building the steps
where we are now the president will
deliver his State of the Union address
there and a little over an hour we'll
have continuing coverage of that of
course all night but first we want to
bring you more news from the newly
volatile Commonwealth of Virginia just
24 hours ago it was a completely
different picture at that point the
state's lieutenant governor Justin
Fairfax fully expected a job promotion
of course because the governor Ralph
Northam was found to have a clan hood on
his med school yearbook page but that's
not how it worked out now Justin Fairfax
himself stands accused of serious
wrongdoing a politics professor from
California called Vanessa Tyson says
that Fairfax sexually assaulted her in
his hotel room at the 2004 Democratic
National Convention in Boston her
description of that is graphic now Tyson
is an active Democrat she's got degrees
from Princeton and the University of
Chicago it's not easy to dismiss her
claims out of hand
and yet Fairfax is he says there was a
sexual encounter between the two but he
describes it as consensual here's the
interesting thing his Democratic
colleagues are standing with him and
against her tonight in other words in
the space of just a few months the
standard for believing sexual assault
accusers has changed completely so here
in case you forgotten is how prominent
Democrats responded to the
unsubstantiated allegations brought
against Supreme Court nominee Brett
Kavanaugh
watch let me just say right at the
outset I believe
dr. Ford I believe to survivor here I
commend her courage I didn't even do you
believe her story well I could tell you
that it really does have a ring of truth
to it but I think the allegations of
Professor Ford are extremely credible I
believe her because she's telling the
truth
no one who is lying does not ask the FBI
to investigate their claims judge
Cavanaugh has not asked to have the FBI
review these claims is that the is that
the reaction of an innocent person it is
not I commend her courage she's telling
the truth
because she is in Kirsten Gillibrand now
at the time of this saying that's night
no they no longer believe all women not
anymore now that as the Washington Post
which you remember was the very first
report on Christine Blasi Ford's
allegations against Brett Kavanaugh and
in fact that same newspaper owned by the
richest man in the world Jeff Bezos as a
vanity project first investigated the
Fairfax story but strangely decided not
to publish it it's just a he-said
she-said story they said pushed by some
professor out in California the irony
it's unbelievable but it's definitely
not worthy of print just so you know the
standard